bonjour à vous merci d'être en direct
avec nous ce matin sur rtl france à
cette période de crise sanitaire et
économique
les gaffes à semble plus puissant que
jamais est ce que vous êtes d'accord
avec ce constat oui plus puissant que
jamais parce que il était dans la place
on a vu que pendant cette période de
confinement et bien les usages
numériques de chacun que ce soit d'un
point de vue personnel ou professionnel
ont explosé le numérique d'ailleurs un
rendu service ça c'est vraiment très
important de le noter
et les outils qui sont les plus
déployées aujourd'hui sont les outils
que nous connaissons de google de
microsoft de facebook
chacun peut être un conte whatsapp c'est
facebook etc
est ce qu'on a observé ces vous savez il
ya 40% de français qui ont créé de
nouveaux compte donc sur des nouveaux
réseaux sociaux plateformes de
messagerie pendant ce confinement une
explosion vraiment des usages et aussi
au sens professionnel
évidemment on peut se poser la question
de savoir est ce que je sais pas au
détriment de nos entreprises européennes
et françaises
or justement les gaffes à son camp même
pointé du doigt notamment en france on
peut citer le groupe amazon
est-ce qu'il ya quand même un impact sur
l'image
aujourd'hui des gaffes a dans ce
contexte de pandémie les l'image des
gars femme est attaqué de toutes parts
d'abord ça date depuis un ou deux ans
d'abord pour des raisons d'exploitation
de données personnelles et puis même
leurs pratiques salariales puisqu'on
parle d' amazon et pour de multiples
raisons
de toute façon ce qui est à attaquer en
premier c'est leur hégémonie
ils empêchent la concurrence de se
développer ils empêchent la l'innovation
et la diversité des solutions d'émerger
et le véritable problème qui a
aujourd'hui et nous en europe nous
devons enfin nous en rendre compte
c'est le problème lié à la souveraineté
de nos peuples la souveraineté en
matière numérique
et puis aussi à l'incidence vous avez vu
l'explosion des fakes news des
problématiques de fausses informations
qui sont diffusés sur les réseaux
sociaux ça ça attaque la démocratie nos
démocraties et donc on il est temps
nous pays européens de nous voilà de
nous lever contre contre ces géants qui
sont maintenant comme l'a dit bruno le
maire
les adversaires des états alors
justement ce que dit bruno le maire il
dit les gars façon les adversaires de
l'état mais est ce que les pouvoirs
publics vont dans le bon sens justement
pour tenter de mettre fin à l'hégémonie
des dégâts fin je crois que la france en
la matière est un précurseur puisque
bruno le maire a vraiment poussé la taxe
gaffe à ce qu'on a appelé la taxe gaffe
a malheureusement qui n'a pas réussi à
convaincre au niveau international mais
qui a été mise en place la récemment
dans les derniers jours en france ça
c'est une très bonne chose
et puis après on a aussi de très belles
initiatives au niveau de la commission
européenne qui se bat contre les dons
contre leur hégémonie contre ce manque à
gagner est aussi d'un point de vue voilà
de la taxation où il ya beaucoup de
problèmes je crois que les pouvoirs
publics prennent conscience de ces
enjeux prennent conscience aussi l'enjeu
non seulement économique mais politique
et oui agissent en ce sens alors il
reste encore beaucoup à faire parce que
vous savez les gars faron des lobby
extrêmement puissant et qui viennent
aussi ce vraiment véritablement faire de
la politique
vous parliez de l'union européenne
justement sur la question de la gestion
des données personnelles il ya quand
même la mise en place du règlement
général sur la protection des données au
sein de l'union européenne vous votre
réseau social ou à l'air donc se veut
aussi respectueux des données
personnelles
ça veut dire que là ya un vrai risque de
voir de plus en plus de personnes
inscrites sur les réseaux sociaux dans
cette période de confinement de sens au
contexte de pandémie mondiale
oui bon de toute façon vous avez raison
le
je peux dire que l'économie dégâts fins
et l'exploitation des données
personnelles essentiellement surtout
google et facebook et maintenant on voit
aussi microsoft qui par ailleurs
exploite les données personnelles des
utilisateurs dans steam c'est ce qu'on a
vu récemment il ya un édito qui est paru
dans le figaro qui expliquait sa ce
qu'est ce qui est incroyable parce que
c'est une solution qui a déployé dans
toutes nos entreprises
aujourd'hui malheureusement on voit une
explosion de ses usages et évidemment
ils bafouent le hergé vous venez de
le mentionner
il bien ils prétendent le le respecter
mais c'est absolument pas le cas et nous
les entreprises en france on essaye de
porter une voix différente soit appelle
la troisième voie du numérique cette
entreprise qui qui produisent des donc
des plateformes nous c'est à une
plateforme collaborative et social chez
waller et qui respectons non seulement
les données personnelles mais qui les
protégeant parce qu'il faut que nos
utilisateurs tous les utilisateurs
d'internet et des technologies retrouve
le contrôle sur leur technologie et
c'est ça le grand danger et le danger
c'est qu'on devienne chacun chacune des
esclaves en fait des outils que nous
utilisons et ça c'est pas c'est pas
acceptable pour le monde de demain et
pour le monde d'aujourd'hui
ce qu'on reproche aux gars fassent et de
favoriser les fractures sociales
est ce que réellement on peut considérer
que les gars façon les grands vainqueurs
de de la crise sanitaire
évidemment ils sont les grands
vainqueurs et et malheureusement c'est
ce que c'est ce qu'a publié l afp la
leurs chiffres et puis il ya aussi le
chiffre de la capitalisation de ces
entreprises
vous savez que amazon a augmenté son
action de 72 %
c'est quasiment fois deux donc c'est à
dire que ces entreprises en moins d'un
an
elles ont doublé de valeur ceseda
valeurs boursières donc elles sont
évidemment elles ont enrichi leurs
dirigeants henri schiller actionnaires
et ça c'est vraiment la limite de ces
entreprises c'est à dire que elles ne
sont plus au service seulement de leurs
utilisateurs de leurs clients mais
évidemment elle développe des des
modèles qui sont d'hégémonie qui ne
permette nul concurrence qui absorbe
toute l'économie et qu'ils prennent
vouloir aider en permanence en réalité
ce sont aujourd'hui c'est peut-être
adversaires des états en tout cas de
sérieux concurrent aux états dans les
rapports de force qui vont s'imposer au
21e siècle il y aura plus seulement il
n'ya plus seulement les et les états
vis-à-vis d'autres états mais maintenant
des puissances qui sont issus des
puissances privées et qui échappe au
contrôle politique aujourd'hui
voyez comme il est difficile d'oser
seulement aborder les sujets de
démantèlement ce qu'on parle de
démantèlement des gaffes à même aux
états unis et se pose très sérieusement
ces questions merci merci beaucoup
thomas fort et je rappelle que vous êtes
directeur général à 2 ou à l'air